vroom vroom owning one of these bad boys
basically a sign you made it you showed
those High School bullies I'm going to
shut his mouth and I'm going to take the
bullies lunch man in this video I'm
going to be asking Miami Supercar owners
how they got rich so I don't have to
start an only fans to get one
huh chase that
[__] he's really we're robbing
his
ass what do you do for a living real
estate real estate how much money do you
make a year over half a million over
half a million dollars what's one piece
of advice you would give to 18 year- old
version of yourself go to school go to
school and study what Finance study
Finance did you lose a lot of money in
crypto uh kind of yeah kind of yeah it's
rebounding though it's good yeah it's
coming back right now
yeah what do you do for a living I'm a
jeweler you're a jeweler yes I am damn
what's one piece of advice you would
give young people looking to get into
business keep working hard don't stop
just keep working hard let's keep
working hard are you a millionaire might
not want to answer that with the tax man
all right so keep working hard any other
advice keep working hard and stay stay
on point you know keep going for that
gold keep going for the gold thank you
bro what do you do for a living eat he
eats that's all he eats oh okay thank
you buddy hey buddy when that's red you
going to walk look at all them look at
all them get them on the camera how you
done get them on the camera how you done
hey the lights red buddy I you done done
all right next interview baby hold on
hold on you want to do a quick interview
what do you do for a living um I sell
people Hope and Dreams all right awesome
bro see you around all
[Music]
bro that's funny rather than running up
to cars on the street all day why not
hit up a friend who just bought a brand
spanking new superar and see what he has
to
say yo what up Ben how you doing what's
up brother I'm not even going to I'm not
going to pretend like this isn't
pre-planned you down to do a quick
interview let's do it all right let's
get in
in what is this thing so this a Porsche
Turbo it's not the new one it's 2019
it's a nice little whip it's a drop top
unfortunately it's not that nice of a
day out so we can't put the top down but
that's the best for the ladies eh yeah
it is you don't have blonde hair it's
best with you have blonde hair blowing
in the wind yeah the convertibles a move
I can I can I can vouch for that all
right let's get on the
[Music]
road
all right so Ben what are you 23 23 23
years old where did you start off to
where you can now afford how much is
this car like 100 Grand it was 160 160
at 23 tax it started just like [__]
trying [__] Bro one thing kind of just
led into the next bro like that's that's
the biggest thing is when I started uh
when I started videography I was like
this is my [__] thing like this is
what I'm going to do with the rest of my
life I'm like this sick and then that
led me into Ecom ad creatives and then
that kind of taught me how to build an
agency and then I started the basketball
marketing agency and then that led me
into the info product world and now
that's what I'm doing so I think if
there's like one key takeaway from my
journey it's just that like you'll never
know exactly how your path is going to
look you're never know going to know
step five when you're on step one but as
long as you go in the right
direction you're things are just going
to unfold you kind of win over luck like
as long as you as long as you go in the
en vicinity things will work out for you
but you have to have enough trust and
faith in yourself that that's all you
need to do yeah it's just like I I call
it pushing the snowball where you do
that first action and it leads into a
bunch of different things how much do
you even have to like work a week right
now doing this kind of thing so I have a
little team now um it's me and two of my
boys that um also kind of have a similar
skill set right now bro honestly like I
I don't work a ton except for when we
get a new client they need like a new
funnel that's if you considered uh going
on dates with new girls job work as well
yeah you'd be [__] horos
buddy that is true are you comfortable
with entering how much you make in a
year yeah I think this year uh with the
agency in total we'll probably do a
little over 800k if you had to start
over again from zero nothing no personal
brand no money what would you do
honestly so like it it'll also depend on
how quickly needed money so there are
different vehicles that I think you can
make money faster but you pigeonhole
yourself a little bit so like if you
need to make 10K a month as quickly as
human humanly possible I'd probably
start with like something like sales
because that's very easy to get into
it's just going to cap you at probably
20 30k a month if you had a bit more
time I think it makes more sense to do
something like an agency or copywriting
or even uh what you're doing with like
teaching people how to how to build up
these Tik Tok accounts um because that's
a real skill that can eventually lead
you into something else where not to say
sales can't do that but it's just a
little bit harder because it's kind of a
one-dimensional skill yeah I know what
you mean with the creativity program
stuff for example like it's not worth my
time to try to scale [__] 10
different accounts to 10K a month like
that the headache with that is going to
be unbelievable but I can have my own
account and then teach other people to
do the same [__]
W that's a weird waiting
on
Benny Boo yes sir thank you so much
thank you for having me on bro been a
pleasure the wise wisdom all right got
to go find some more super cars yes sir
good luck all right Ben just dropped me
off the weather is Absol hopefully we
run into someone else soon two hours
later what's up bro what are you doing
here dude I was just I was just looking
for people with super cars can I get in
it's raining bro it's raining how do you
open this [__] when did you get this
thing literally last night bro last
night you bought got
this what are you 21 21 21 no it feels
weird for me too like for anyone who
thinks like that these guys that are
young like a super car they're just like
at a different level when I get to
realize like I'm still super like
childish like I would rip like a pack of
gushers where I'll [__] those up you'll
[__] up some G I'm a normal guy dude
like I I go on dates I'm a normal guy
the fact is is that I realize there's
super easy ways to make a lot of money
and I leveraged those and then you can
just buy little toys like this what did
you get started with with making money
so a lot of people think it was like 2 3
years it's been a half a decade I
dropped out of high school at 16 I'm
about to turn 22 so it's actually close
to but you dropped out of high school
yeah I have no GED what the [__] if you
had to start from zero what would you do
the true key is realizing that the grass
is green where you water it not on the
other side do something and do it really
[__] well and then get a cool toy
don't don't spread your focus out all
over the place basically exactly dude
everyone oh my god dude I literally this
was happening to me my first few years
I'm like dude I have to get into this
new style of editing or you need this
you need that like this person look at
Tate bro Tate crushed everyone ripped
his editing style and a few months later
I think you were the person who put
beond you're like bro like have your own
Vibe and that's the key dude you got to
realize that the grass is green where
you water it where you put your time and
effort that's where [__] gets better
that's where life gets
good I got to go buy some [__] you want
to come yeah I'm
down what would you say the biggest way
money has impacted your life having
money it definitely doesn't buy
happiness I think that word buy
happiness is shitty Becker says he's
like yeah you think money doesn't buy
happiness we enjoy spending 70% of your
life [__] working week to week yeah I
mean if you're working a job like being
an entrepreneur doing any side hustle
it's just buying time and that's
priceless Jacob I appreciate the
interview yeah that was obviously
planned I'm not going to pretend like
that wasn't planned you know I'm not
going to be faking that [__] but uh yeah
you guys will know which ones aren't
planned and uh yeah thank you so much
for the interview bro that was [__]
lit I'm going to go try to find some
more [__] we were just chilling
downstairs um as I Wasing Jacob and we
ran into one of his friends what's your
name Dash right dash yeah Dash you're
you're down to do a quick interview yeah
all right let's do it wait what is this
car this Aston Martin Vantage Aston
Martin
Vantage what do you do for a living I'm
the founder of fan bases we' built a
marketplace where celebrities athletes
and influencers can sell digital
experiences to their fans so what what's
it like building like a that sounds like
a pretty [__] big business managing
all those employees doing all that [__]
at 24 what's that like it's been
exciting but a lot of [__] work I'll
tell you that how much are you doing are
you guys doing a year right now between
I'll tell you this between all my
businesses total we're doing um close to
about 25 million a
year 25 Milli a year right now at 24
yeah yeah yeah that's [__] insane wow
if you had to start from zero like you
had nothing I don't know if you have a
personal brand right now but you had all
you had was your skill sets what would
you do first thing I would do is you
know basically I like to structure my
business in two ways have some sort of
cash flow streams coming in and then use
that to propel a long-term Vision kind
of business if you had to tell your
17-year-old self one piece of advice
what would you say when I was 17 I
actually sold my first business but what
did you sell that for um it was in know
that was in a large exit that was in you
know mid6 figure range uh but at 17
that's pretty [__] f it it was good
money for the time for sure in my
opinion I never want to be the you know
most successful person in my friend
group that means I'm in the wrong friend
groups you know is just kind of leveling
that up and putting the right people
around you exposing yourself to
Opportunities having good network is
probably the most rewarding thing that
you can have and I wish you I've been
building my network for a while but I
you know wish I did more even when I was
younger does a superar buy happiness uh
I wouldn't say it buys happiness but it
definitely creates a little bit of
happiness it's want to drive it helps
how does it help with the ladies uh I
have a girlfriend so it helped um helped
secure the bag yeah I guess so awesome
all right bro I appreciate
it what is this [__] thing we got
another McLaren another McLaren look at
that I know how to open the door now bro
are they all different
underneath on the bottom under the
handle under the handle oh [__]
if you had to talk to 18-year-old Kyle 6
years ago what would you tell yourself
honestly keep doing what you're doing
just that's it you don't want to [__] up
The Path just keep doing what you're
doing keep doing what you're doing I
played like a very like high risk High
award game so yeah I mean 18 was right
when I dropped out of college so that
was kind of like the contemplation of if
it was going to end up well well were
you studying in college um I mean I I
was there for 34 days but yeah yeah I
was I was in college for year and I
passed I mean I failed every class yeah
know it was uh business administration
business that's the funniest [__]
thing going to school to study business
like just start one bro does super car
buy happiness I would say it's uh it's
temporary happiness temporary happiness
yeah temporary happiness it can
definitely like provide like small
amounts of Joy on the day-to-day basis
buying the car is always fun whipping to
the gym is always fun but like I don't
think it leads to fulfillment how does
it help with the ladies does it actually
do stuff like it helps with the girls
either um I would say if you use it
wisely if you use it wisely and use it
in the right ways like I would say not
just be the guy who's just going around
like flashing the car but if you do in
the right ways it can definitely help
it's credibility I guess in a sense yeah
if it's all you have you're [__]
basically yeah exactly if you have a
superar but you can't talk to people
then you're cooked if you had to start
from zero again nothing all you have is
your skill sets in your brain what would
you do I would do the exact same thing I
did now although I would have done a
lead generation program for buying
buying and flipping Ecom Brands back in
the day cuz I could have killed it in
that but I didn't know like how to
actually build uh a sales system what's
the biggest way that money has impacted
your life my definition of happiness and
like what really makes me happy is doing
amazing things with the people I care
about most which money allows that to
happen easily so it's like yeah I could
go on you know like a camping trip with
my family without much money but also
just being able to like take your family
take your friends on you know a trip to
St Trope or St Barts Etc that's like it
makes uh happiness a lot more accessible
so it makes your life easier all right
bro later I'll see you B see you like
subscribe and if you want to learn from
me live on how you can make money
posting short form content I'm hosting a
free live call later this week whenever
you're watching it so if you want to
register check the link at the top of
the description to see if there's any
more spots later
guys iash I burn I walk in the room it's